she's like very she accepts me perfectly
as I am I've never complained about Jim
ever no she doesn't like I hate the way
I look right now I know I look gross and
fat no one thinks that but Jem but but
literally she's it's genuine I know
Nikki W off and she'll tell me you look
great I'm fine with that and then
there's a part of me that thinks no she
wants you to have a stroke fat boy so
she gets the then I would have just
poisoned
you yeah after this next tour maybe let
me just get some money once you get that
YouTube Revenue going to the Norwegian
bank account oh hopefully Two Broke
Girls was in Norway was it oh I think I
knew that yes I watched out when I was
like nine a little oh my gosh okay
that's one of them yeah she just did it
to me oh yeah yes without meaning she
just did it to me watch you make someone
feel old when you say I watched that
when I was
nine brutal well I think I was do you
know what it's like knife to the heart
do you know what it's like when I'm
putting a kiss poster and she's like oh
my God my father would love that he's
younger than
you yeah
that was such a nice way to call me old
in a way that you didn't even mean it
that's my life that's exact it's never
mean it's always meant to be loving but
uh yeah she's she's great I mean Nikki
is not I I I one of the reasons we work
is because her sense of humor is so good
um she is legitimately funny and she
makes fun of me and she never she's
unbreakable if I make fun of it's like
it's the way I important to have Irony
when you're me you know most trans
people have a sense of humor about all
of that we make
where are they like come through please
they're not on Twitter fighting with
everybody so it's like all trans people
are so uptight and I'm like no the cool
ones aren't on Twitter yelling at
everyone trying to get people fired in
the Human Resources office they have
better things to do they have lives
they're not thinking about it I've never
met people where the megaphone these
people who are behind this megaphone I
haven't met one of them I've only gu
seen them on Twitter I don't know but
trans people are no different than
anybody else no different than any other
group Men Women racially this group
there most people are fine and then
there's a loud group that wants to
pretend to be upset because it's
empowering and then there's a group
who's legit upset yeah um it's like any
other group and then it's like people
make trans an umbrella term when it's
not like it's not at all an umbrella
term like if I'm transgender it
literally means change the gender you
were assigned at Birth yeah hello and
now you're putting it like in my base
where I had to go for me where I had to
go and get a diagnosis I had to do all
this and now you're just calling
yourself trans it's not that easy you
know I learned how to make eggs yeah egg
whites for him cuz he eats like he's got
AIDS
crazy God I can't I can't with this has
been our first interview too this really
fun oh my God yall are the best I can
talk to you forever yeah it's so happy
we're doing you it's just like I don't
know it's really heartwarming it's
giving me so much um Faith it's like you
know um I'm going to out you guys for a
second for being the cutest when I
having a baby shower was really hard for
me cuz it's weird to get attention
around something that's not being a
performer like when you guys get married
it's going to feel weird yeah cuz you're
kind of like like why is everyone so
happy for me I haven't made you know I
haven't like earned this or something
and when you guys came to the baby
shower it made so like me so much to me
in and everyone I mean my you know our
friends are animals like they want
nothing more than to just say horrible
things about people and they're just
like they're the cutest her friends are
my friends and it's like a bunch of old
guys with another 60-year-old man all
the time I want to be way to the girlies
where are they come through cuz the
people who follow me now are only gems
trucker fans get a boob job you should
get boobs and it's like that's my
account Throw Some D's on that bitch
that's Jim
Florentine yeah so that's where I'm at
now get a boob job but you know yeah
they say that sometimes like I don't do
jobs I was very clear I do no jobs zero
kinds of jobs I mean it used to take you
two and a half days to do your laundry
so I guess it's yeah it's fair moldy I
don't get get get it what are some other
things about America that are a
delightful because I I think it's it's
Americans we take for granted this great
country we live in and so it's nice to
talk to someone that yeah she loves all
everything but I think Americans are
really nice people like at least
everyone that I've met they're just so
nice so cool not awkward people like
they're not stiff and weird and H like
they're done in Norway like oh I think
every state in America feels a little
bit like a different country have you
been to other states in America that
you're like what the it's so different
i' I've been on the road with Jim a
couple of times and there's places where
I can't even get Easter salad like it's
insane you've been to Cincinnati yeah we
been to Cleveland we've been to
obviously La San Francisco Gilford New
Hampshire bir show oh nice I want to go
to the South sometimes maybe South is
awesome yes have you been in Texas yet
or no no no not yet oh you'll do great
in Texas yeah they will love you yeah
this is like Dallas like this is you
know do they all have guns there in
Texas is that cuz in Florida we were
just in Sarasota and I learned that
everyone carries there 80% is it the
same in Texas they carry 80% oh I don't
know if it's 80% do you want a gun yes
see this is what B like I she's this is
true she's the only person and and I
reloaded in Jim's mouth
this